I'm Carolyn Davis I'm a former submarine
officer from the U.S Navy
for the GSB I was in the United States
Army I was a captain and I was a
Blackhawk pilot before I came to the GSB
I was an infantry officer in the Marine
Corps where I led a platoon of around 40
Marines and then I went into information
operations which is a mix of cyberspace
operations and psychological operations
initially what led me to the GSB was the
opportunity to pursue higher education
and take advantage of a prestigious
scholarship that the Navy had warded me
to pursue education at a private
Institution
it really does seem like there's
something in the air that makes people
want to give a little bit more than just
to themselves they want to be a part of
something bigger a lot of the reasons
why I was interested in the GSP were the
kind of values that made me interested
in the Navy to start with so wanting a
really high quality of Education wanting
adventure and the opportunity to like
keep learning GSB really drew me in
because it's all about the whole person
and helping you figure out what you're
going to do and help you find out how
you can contribute to the world and how
you can use your skills and abilities
and passions every time I see a veteran
out here in the in Town Square I always
go up and say hi there's always somebody
that you can have lunch with talk about
classes with talk about recruiting with
it's been awesome to be a part of that
Community where you can just kind of be
yourself at all times there's always a
veteran that understands what it's like
what it's like to have that military
lifestyle Stanford offers a number of
resources to support veterans across
campus not just isolated to the GSB one
example people is the office of military
affiliate communities some of the things
that they provide is access and
understanding to the financial aid
benefits that are available VA benefits
that are available and they'll help you
navigate the tuition process and just be
there throughout the duration of your
tenure at Stanford what surprised me the
most about the veteran Community has
just been how tight-knit we have become
and the level of support that the
veterans Club gives to an individual is
they kind of make that transition from
the military world the civilian World
truly is something that a lot more
people need than they might think since
arriving at the GSB I've been pleasantly
surprised with the amount of diversity
that exists within our military cohort
our veterans span across all services
and within those Services a variety of
communities exist one of the things
that's most impressive to me is the fact
that there's both prior enlisted service
members here and also officers
I think all the Vets can say they've
dealt with difficult conversations
whether it's mentoring someone
one-on-one turning around a small team
making high pressure decisions so those
insights
are very transferable to other careers
and I think it's something our
classmates are really hungry to learn
about and the reason why they might come
to business school coming from the
military you've done some things you've
you know you name it you've been in the
field you've been deployed you've flown
helicopters you've done raids you've
done a ton of stuff that a lot of people
have never even thought about and so
being able to contribute to my
classmates experience by sharing what
I've done and what I've been through has
been something I've been really proud of
and glad to contribute
so what I would say to any veteran is
just apply you know take a shot and
realize that you have the opportunity to
contribute and make a difference whether
you're enlisted or whether you're an
officer I think those things that we
bring to the table is a different type
of perspective and experience that is
going to be a huge contributor to the
classrooms for any
do not doubt yourself I know it seems to
scared for me outside like what do you
have to offer you have a ton so do not
doubt yourself that's what I would tell
myself a few years ago when I was
applying of you're not crazy just go for
it and you have a lot to offer